Speaker 1: Let's see if we can squeeze in
more people. Let's go to is it does
Desmond or Desmond from Birmingham?
Desmond. Desmond. You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, what's up? Can you hear me? Fine.
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Cool. Cool.
Okay. Awesome. So I had a question, but I'm
not sure if it's, like, better to preface
my question with some, like, context first.
Speaker 1: Probably not. Let's get the question
first and I'll tell you if we need context.
Speaker 3: Okay. Okay. Cool. Okay.
Do you think that concepts like let me think of
a good example of an adjective. Okay, it's fine.
I guess it's not important. Do you think that
concepts like social welfare policies, I guess
I don't know if this is the correct category
to put that in, but things like universal,
like single payer health care or like public more
affordable like colleges, universal like public
colleges and stuff like that. Concepts like that
that are obviously a lot more like commonplace
within like Europe. Do you think that things like
that are kind of completely lost on the US? No.
Speaker 1: Lost and lost in what sense?
Speaker 3: And kind of like. Like, for example,
like I live in Birmingham, Alabama. And if I
tell someone around here that I think universal
single payer health care is cool, and then I
think that, you know, public college is cool
there. They might call me a satanic communist or
something like that. You know what I mean? Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, that makes.
Speaker 3: Me feel like it's really
the population.
Speaker 1: Yeah. No, that's the of.
There are people who may be against these things
for fiscal reasons or whatever the case may be.
But very few are going to say that you're
a satanic communist because of your
you're favoring that. So, no, I don't think it's
lost on people at all. And in fact, I would argue
that because of people's increased understanding
of the ways in which they are getting screwed,
even if they don't understand who's screwing them,
I think that it's actually a great environment now
to be talking more about the fact that
these are just basic, not controversial
parts of many Western countries, economies and
societies. My friend, I got to run. I appreciate
the call. There's Desmond from Birmingham. I
apologize. I cannot take any more calls today,
but we will take more calls in the future